- But yes, I was in one
of your music videos
for Behind These Hazel Eyes.
- [Kelly] The wedding, yes.
- The wedding, I was a wedding guest.
And yeah, there was a scene where you run
down the aisle of the church,
fling open the doors.
- Well, you don't know this part.
Joseph Kahn who directed it,
who's like directs
movies, he's incredible.
And he's done a ton of my videos.
No one actually told me
that there were stairs
when you open the doors.
And I am full on.
I don't know if you've noticed.
So, like, I literally, in that video,
they said, we want you to
run out 'cause you're so mad
'cause your bridesmaid
has been with your man
and it's like this whole thing.
And I was like okay.
So I was in track.
I ran.
And I ran so hard, I didn't actually fall,
I like flew down the stairs
like with this giant dress.
Didn't get one bruise, thank you.
(audience cheering)
- Now, I feel like what
you didn't get to see
was what I saw.
- [Kelly] Kelly Clarkson die.
- The direction for the
people at the wedding
was Kelly's gonna run by you.
You're shocked, you're
stunned, there's drama.
And watch her as she runs through.
So, we all were watching you.
We watched the doors fling open,
and then we watched you free fall forward.
- It was like (laughing).
- Down a set of stairs,
and then there was like an odd calm.
- Pause, and you can
hear everybody go (gasp).
- Is she?
- Dead?
- Still alive?
What happened to her?
And I remember it was like 15 second,
like deafening silence,
and then we hear from down
the stairs, "I'm good!"
(laughing)
- I think I literally got up
and did the like Mary Katherine Gallagher.
- [Danny] In a full wedding
dress, too, I might add.
- And a full wedding dress.
Yeah, and I literally looked at Joseph
and was like thanks for the heads up
with the whole stair scenario.
- That could have gone a different way.
- We actually have video
of Danny's big moment
in my video, as well.
(audience cheering)
- [Danny] Okay.
There, wait, can you see me?
There I am!
- [Kelly] Yeah!
There I am, there I am.
- Hold on, there I am!
(audience cheering)
Yes!
- I feel like when you
have to go "there I am!
"Oh wait, there!
"There I am!"
I feel like it's not a starring role.
- Welcome to my early acting career.